I told you about six or seven weeks ago that
there's a good chance that the DNC changes
the debate requirements in order to allow
the late Michael Bloomberg late and sorry,
Michael Bloomberg is a lot, is allowed, uh,
alive.
I mean the late to the race, Michael Bloomberg
and the quite frankly rapidly surging Michael
Bloomberg into the debates and it's happening.
It's happening exactly as I predicted and
now we will see what the other candidates
say.
The requirements to qualify for debates have
included a combination of polling numbers
and donor requirements, total number of donors
and donors in a, I think it's at least 20
stays and then pulling an early States billionaire.
Michael Bloomberg entered this race very,
very late and just bought his way in.
He hasn't been raising money from individual
donors.
He doesn't need to, he's a turbo billionaire.
He has a lot more money than Donald Trump
and he's just been funding his own campaign
which means he wouldn't be able to qualify
for the debates because he's not accepting
individual donations.
That being said, Bloomberg has been doing
really well.
Bloomberg has bought his way in.
He's in fourth place.
I told you last week he was like a half point
ahead of Pete, Buddha judge.
Now he's almost a point and a half ahead of
Pete boot edge edge and he is solidly more
solidly in fourth place.
And as I said before, I believe Bloomberg
strategy of pouring money into super Tuesday
States is going to end up with him doing no
worse than third.
I believe that Elizabeth Warren has lost all
momentum and that it is possible that Michael
Bloomberg ends up with as many or more delegates
than the number Elizabeth Warren ends up with
in third place.
I believe by the time it's all said and done,
Bloomberg will be no worse than third place,
but without being in the debates, it's going
to be tougher.
So the DNC signaled a couple of weeks ago.
Yeah, we might change the rules once people
start voting.
We knew it would be possibly to let Michael
Bloomberg in and the way they did it is by
saying, listen, before any votes are cast,
we have our requirements, we have a donor
requirement, we have a polling requirement.
Once people start voting, people are speaking,
we should consider just going by polling support
and results in the primaries and case and
point exactly as predicted after New Hampshire,
just in time for Bloomberg to get onto the
debate stage before Nevada and South Carolina
and super Tuesday, the DNC is going to double
the polling requirement, but they are getting
rid of the individual donor requirement altogether.
So starting in mid-February, if Michael Bloomberg
can keep growing his support, he will be on
the debate stage and hilariously it's conceivable
that Bloomberg will be in and Pete Buddha
judge will not.
But that's an unlikely scenario which we'll
see the new requirements are you need at least
10% support in four-poles between January
15 and February 18 or 12% in two poles in
Nevada and South Carolina to be at the February
19th debate.
If you earn at least one delegate in Iowa
or New Hampshire, you also can be at that
next debate so low well that in the next day.
So there's one Friday, the one after that.
So when you look at these requirements, Bloomberg
had 10% in a recent poll.
If you go back to January 15th, he I think
was over 10 and some other polls it, we'll
see if they're allowed in.
There's a very specific list of which polls
are allowed.
So the polling requirement might or might
not qualify him, but his trajectory suggests
that Bloomberg could end up in that, uh, end
of February debate.
As of today, only Biden, Bernie and Warren
qualify.
We're still two weeks out.
Pete boot edge, edge, not qualified as of
right now, if I'm the supporter of one of
these other candidates, I'm furious when I
see this.
There is logic to listen.
People are voting now, so we don't need donor
accounts.
It makes some sense.
But the thing is people aren't really going
to be voting for Bloomberg in these upcoming
primaries.
Bloomberg is barely doing anything in Iowa
and in New Hampshire.
He's skipping right to pouring money into
and resources into the super Tuesday States.
Nothing about Bloomberg situation really has
changed other than pulling support.
Now at the same time, as I said before, if
you step back and you look and you see you've
got Bernie Biden and Warren and then you've
got Bloomberg and then behind that is Pete
budaj who's been in basically every debate.
It is weird not to have Bloomberg at the debates.
I like it when you see the level of support
he has.
You would say that's someone we probably should
be hearing from, but as I said before, these
are the rules that the DNC set.
Now they have the risk of enraging people
if they change the rules to let a Bloomberg
in which they are at least potentially doing.
We'll see if Bloomberg ends up getting in.
Let me say one other thing.
Does it not matter that much if you're in
the debates at this point?
I don't know the answer to this, but my, my
point is Pete boot edge edge has been in every
debate and he's lost support for the last
three months.
Weekly.
Pete boot edge edge is losing support.
Bloomberg with door to door campaigning and
YouTube and television advertising has passed.
Klobuchar has passed.
Tool C has passed.
Tom Stire has passed Andrew Yang and most
recently has passed Buddha judge.
Maybe the debates aren't that important.
Let me know what you think.
We're going to follow up on this on our Instagram
page at David Pakman show.
Follow me on Instagram at David dot.
Pacman.
We will take a quick break coming up next
Kansas city.
When
I say Kansas city, what state do you think
of?
Let me talk about that after
the break,